when it comes to the mar-a-lago raid  many libs don't understand that the  president has the absolute authority to  declassify material there are processes  for declassifying material the president  is not bound by those processes the very  moment that the president decides to  declassify material that material is  declassified politifact writes quote  we're in uncharted territory on the  issue of criminally prosecuting a former  president over mishandling classified  documents there is no legal precedent to  look to for guidance it raises all sorts  of constitutional implications and it is  anyone's guess how it would play out  same goes for the new york times which  admits that quote the classification  system is not really enforced by  criminal law but rather just  bureaucratic punishments it determines  whether or not a president such as  donald trump mishandled classified  information which the president cannot  do because he is the president